let's understand how we got here
after Roe v Wade was overturned
the department of health and Human Services had a sneaking suspicion
that red states were going to start denying emergency
life saving care to pregnant people
because…America. so they sent out a little PSA to states being like
don't forget that you
federal obligations to provide emergency care to pregnant people
who are still people.
see  EMTALA is a federal law that says
if you're a hospital and someone comes in with an emergency medical condition
you have to provide stabilizing treatment okay
so the department was like
hey states
don't forget about EMTALA
and here is specifically what they said
they said just as a reminder
if a physician believes that a pregnant patient comes to the ER
and is experiencing an emergency medical condition
and an abortion is a stabilizing treatment
that is necessary to resolve the condition
the physician must provide the treatment
literally just saying
if somebody comes in with a medical emergency and they need an abortion
you have to treat them. so what do you think the state of Texas does?
it sues The Department of health and Human Services
just let that sink in the state of Texas sued over this
this is what they're like no
do we have to don't make us do that
can't we just let her suffer
and because we live in hell
the district court sided with the state of Texas
and basically told the department
just let the state of Texas do whatever they want
because we actually live in a place that's one step below how
the Fifth Circuit affirmed the district court's order
so the Biden administration appealed to the Supreme Court
they were like um
hey you should hear this
like really crazy stuff that's going on
and the Supreme Court declined to hear the case
they were like now we feel like it's fine the way it is
okay so where does all that leave us
so as of right now
the federal government
cannot require states to provide pregnant people with emergency care
States like Texas can force pregnant people to lose their organs
to become brain dead to get so sick that they go into septic shock
and so much more all because they refuse to provide emergency
life saving abortions I'm the feminist lawyer
follow me if you enjoy being miserable